the destructive Wildfire is burning
everything in its path
thousands of firefighters are on the
ground
but the Flames are spreading fast
Jerry Cal has been ordered to leave the
area but he says he doesn't want to go
this is our home
we just feel like I feel like we're
gonna
do what we can to to at least uh
have a chance
but some didn't have that chance
overnight the fire destroyed their homes
and years of memories
I have
from my grandmother
the Lord's Supper she had crocheted
from the 1934 World's Fair in New York
it means I hanged out about my bed
I saved the papers and I saved that
the States was dropped in decades at an
intense summer heat of fueling the
Flames racing through a largely dry land
it's it's really heartbreaking because
it's been year after year you know and
just to think about the entire State
here and everywhere else you know
there's been so many fires and so many
homes
the cause of this fire is still being
investigated but scientists say it's
climate change that's made wildfires in
California more common and unpredictable
Priyanka Gupta Al Jazeera